hey guys it is Bev nine or as I
accidentally typo'd in the headline of
the script of fab nine other what that
is but i'll definitely be catching the
Netflix series after i'm done with
unfortunate events and santa clarita
died i feel we've gotten off track
here's the news first up Mass Effect
Andromeda is dropping Paragon and
renegade options but before you react
the way I did and go all here's why that
might not be a bad thing creative
director Mac Walters told official Xbox
Magazine that the Paragon and renegade
options felt very Shepherd and since we
no longer have a shepherd they didn't
really make any sense he added what we
have now is based more around agreeing
and disagreeing the reason I like that
is because in the trilogy it's like I'm
gonna play Paragon and then you know
which way you're moving the stick on
every conversation you don't have to
think about it because you're just going
to hit Paragon every time the new system
is designed to help shift away from
those binary moral choices and Walters
explained with agree and disagree it
changes by the circumstance and it
changes by the character you're talking
to so you have to actually be more
engaged in what's going on the new
system also includes four different
tones of voice which you can use to
express yourself so it's inquisition
they've just made Inquisition next up
South Park the fractured but Hall has
been delayed again yeah roll the thing
during its latest earnings call Ubisoft
announced the game which was supposed to
arrive between january and march of this
year will now arrive between april of
2017 and March 2018 the game was
originally slated to arrive in december
of last year Ubisoft CEO is gamma added
that the publisher is set to release
Just Dance 2017 for a Nintendo switch at
launch as well as multiple other games
for the system this year which will be
quote very strong for the machine he
added that Ubisoft won't be releasing as
many new IP going forward and will
instead focus on growing its existing
brands
finally a price drop is coming for the
ps4 although it is only temporary sony
announced that the ps4 slims uncharted 4
and infinite warfare bundles are coming
down to 250 bucks from 299 from every 12
to 25 additionally the walmart exclusive
glacier white infinite warfare ps4
bundle is also part of the deal the
bundles both include their respective
games and a 500 gigabyte system although
the infinite warfare bundle also throws
in a modern warfare remastered code
unfortunately this price card is for the
u.s. only that is everything I got for
you today do leave me your thoughts in
the comment section head to gamespot for
stories on fallout 4 and Rainbow six
siege and I will catch you with our top
five tomorrow